you look incredible you're so sweet
thank you thank you thank you and only
but a goodie all the best yes thank you
thank you your fondest memory of seeing
Brooke Shields be it on the small screen
the big screen modeling or advertisement
okay who can forget Brook and her Calvin
Kleins I'll never forget that I will
never forget her Blue Lagoon
a lot of the movies that she did very
early on I was just so taken by her she
had such a presence about her she was so
beautiful and now I get to call her a
friend I've actually gotten to know
Brooke over the years and she's just an
incredible woman she's morphed into this
young thing who's now become this
incredible woman who is standing on her
own two feet and embracing and owning
everything that she's been through he
has been through a lot and I mean this
documentary is incredible of course your
colleague George Stephanopoulos his wife
Ally yes and I gotta say we're so proud
of you and Al and sing Al back on for
today thank you then he's back to
driving me crazy of course so there you
go he's doing he's doing well oh my gosh
it's just great to be back it's so great
to see him back on morning TV though I
mean there's just like when he's not
present there's a smile missing there's
a presence that definitely that's
definitely missing from the show but how
are you doing because caring for someone
thank you still and going through a
medical emergency thank you thank you I
appreciate that and I think a lot of
people don't realize that and I never
realized that that being a caregiver is
really taxing exhausting frightening all
of those things and I never went through
this before anything like this and I
hope I'll never do it again but it's uh
it's tough it's tough I'm still kind of
I think recuperating I'm still kind of
tired I'm still mentally exhausted but
you know what I'm grateful and just bask
in the moment and just be happy that
he's well and we're all well
what got you through those moments
Deborah
um I would say you know my spirituality
God I'm really very spiritually focused
so I would say um my my faith my
spiritual Faith got me through it my
family got me through it my colleagues
got me through it colleagues many of
whom are here today you know Lifted Me
Up in times when I felt like I just
couldn't make it people were there and
texting and emailing and calling and
that made all the difference Al knows
he's got a good woman so take it easy
[Music]